hey what's up it's Jesse I'm here at the
Wolfram tech conference 2018 if you
weren't tuned in yesterday I'm basically
just talking with developers and other
interesting people I'm using Wolfram
technology in really cool ways and I'm
sitting here with the frita can you tell
us a little bit about what you do here
at Wolfram and also what you're doing
here at the conference specifically sure
um I work with the Wolfram you team so
we are sort of the hub for everything to
do with learning and training with the
Wolfram technology at the conference
specifically we hold a full day of pre
conference training so we did that on
Tuesday we conducted four different so I
did the data science course I was
teaching that morning and evening and
then we were also doing courses like a
crash course for scientists and
engineers and then we also did an image
processing of course the same thing in
the data science course like can you
just briefly describe sort of like what
sure
so you as you know we are promoting this
multi-paradigm data science approach
from Wolfram site
this was the intention for the course to
present the multi-paradigm workflow so
yeah I mean yes the data science
workflow is pretty much same but we
bring this something extra to the table
and the multi-paradigm data science
workflow where we see that you know you
have this incredible collection of tools
like computational tools that you can
use while you're going through the
workflow so for the training that is
what we try to highlight we present it a
very simple workflow you know question
wrangle explore analyze and communicate
but at every stage we showed that you
can branch out for wrangling you can
work with different kinds of data and
then for exploration you can use all our
built-in functions access to our
state-of-the-art algorithms in the
analyze phase we can do similar things
thank you know not be restricted by the
field you're working with or the
specific kind of data but leverage
Wolfram's collection of algorithms to
you know try out different things across
the field and then finally you know we
do a good job of visualizing things
sharing things on the web by cloud
publishing stuff so we showed how you
could use that to finally communicate
the results of your analysis so this is
the workflow that we went through and in
the course nice awesome so well from you
can you before we sort of get into
what's new about it can you tell me a
little bit about what it is
like achievable sure so we're from you
as I said is like our learning hub and
our idea is can I show you our website
yeah yeah so this is the way from you
website and the I think the thought
process was that you know you if you
want to learn about data science if you
want to learn about mathematics or you
know just like basic coding the idea is
you come to word from you and you should
be able to find some videos some MOOCs
like online learning courses then we
also host live webinar series so you are
able to join one of those and then learn
about this topic that you're interested
in and the idea is you do not have to
know the Wolfram language we will teach
you whatever it is that you want to
learn but we will be using the Wolfram
language while doing it because it's
just so easy to do that yeah um so how
long is Wolfram you been around about a
year okay so working it's still like we
are trying to put in a lot of things in
there we have some very exciting plans
coming up new MOOCs coming up
well Devendra talked about the calculus
right that's our latest yeah what are
the other MOOCs so we started out with
the MOOC version of Stephens book
elementary introduction to the Wolfram
language so we converted that into a
MOOC and so there were you know videos
there were notebooks scratchpad things
you could work on and then the calculus
move the other thing that we have been
also working on you know we have the
word from summer school every summer
which is like a really nice thing and so
we got all the lectures from what the
students listen to and then we converted
those into a MOOC so now you can go in
and I think they can show you here let's
see going to language here
here and here you see this hostel from
summer school this is from 2017 and
right now we are in the process of
putting together 2018
so you can actually go into the course
and you can look at all these lectures
here that the students at 2017 Wow and
it's very nice like it starts out very
basic you know as it says getting
started with the world from language so
walks you through the very basic concept
moves on to advanced topics and then
very specific application image
processing or you know blockchain things
like that then of course machine
learning because it could focus on
machine learning cloud development and
so on so you can go in so we have the
lecture notebooks we have the lecture
videos and then we have like the scratch
pad but you can try out things as you
are looking at the videos and you know
listening to the lecture wow that's
really nice can you tell me a little bit
about where the calculus MOOC does it
have the same yeah let's take a look at
that and you know we are we are trying
to build on our experience feedback that
we received from some of our users and
also our own thing like our own take on
it what is working what is not working
so every successive move has something
better in it so we're trying to improve
the stuff so forth for now for example
well the AI wo was really nice with the
calculus what we've also brought in is
there's the lecture of course the video
the lecture notebook here and then we
also have these problem sessions oh nice
where the instructor actually goes
through some
problems with the students and then you
also have the quiz and so the student is
able to actually take the quiz and what
we are hoping to get out is sort of a
certification program so we ensure they
have gone through the videos they've
learnt the material and then they take
the quiz and then they can put in a like
they can submit an application for
certification and so if you've taken
this course you can be certified that
you have taken the calculus course so
you'd be certified with like calculus
knowledge with the language exactly so I
I guess where do you see some of this
move framework with will from you going
in the next couple of years all right so
we are definitely trying to like
standardize it working very hard behind
the scenes that there's an incredible
team that who who is trying to you know
make sure that with every new you know
there's no end to topics there's always
exciting new topics coming up right so
that and a lot of people already have
these lectures sort of planned out they
have the notebook so we are trying to
set up a framework so that we are able
to take those lecture notebooks you know
basic mathematical notebooks and then
quickly convert them into the smooth
framework online but also we want to
have like a list of you know best
practices like to remember these things
have the quiz in there have you know
keep in mind that you know short sweet
lectures are much better than like
longer ones people gonna start wandering
so sort of a list of best practices that
instructors could use whether were from
folks are external instructors who have
have these have been teaching these
wonderful mathematical courses or
Wolfram language courses for a while so
we would love to like hear from them if
they have course ideas and then
hopefully we can we can see what we can
do with those awesome well thanks for
hanging out with me and talk about me
for you thanks thanks for talking to me
um I mean thanks for yours
so later we'll be talking to some other
people Wolfram so stick around for that
[Music]